[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصادر معكم عبد القادر عيات
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع وحدات
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
نبداها بهذه الصور الان هل صور المباشره
من التي تعيش على الرفع هجوم جوي مكثف منذ
ايام
ثم الى الخرطوم هذه الصور المباشره ايضا
تعيش على وقع اشتباكات وحديث بشان اتفاق
وشيك على هدنه جديده مدتها عشره
حيث تم اعلان الاتفاق عن هذه الهدنه وفي
مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
اذا توقيع اتفاق جديد على هدنه انسانيه
لعشره ايام في المرحله الثانيه من اعلان
جده
بلينكينو في اتصال بالبرهان استمرار اعمال
العنف من طرفي الصراع ويشدد على اهميه
ايصال مساعدات يحتاجها السودانيون بشده
وميدانيا نسقوا ضربات الجويه في الخرطوم
في ارتفاع والمعارك في ابرز مدن الغرب
السوداني تتسع
في شرق اوكرانيا معارك باخموت تحتدم وغموض
بشان مالاتها الجيش الاوكراني ينفي سقوط
المدينه والمتحدث باسم الجبهه الشرقيه
يؤكد للجزيره استمرار المواجهات في محيطها
بهدف استنزاف مقاتل فاجنر رئيس شركه
فاميلي يقول ان قواته السيطره على كامل
المدينه ويتحدث عن تسليمها قريبا للجيش
الروسي
في قمه الحضرها زين انسقي مجموعه السبع
تشدد على دعم كياب والانفتاح على تدريب
تيارها على طائرات اف 16
وتحذير للصين بالمواقف احاديه يقول ان
قرارات القمه تهدف لاحتواء مزدوج لروسيا
والصين
تحتاج وتتهم مجموعه السبع بزعزعه
الاستقرار وتجاهل مخاوفها
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم الانتخابات في
تركيا العمليه جاريه وخصوصا ما يتعلق ببدء
تصويت الاتراك في الخارج في الجوله جوله
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الثانيه وما شهدته من
اقبال كثير في يومها الاول باستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي عن دلاله الاقبال على
التصويت في الجوله الرئاسيه الثانيه وجاءت
النتائج على الشكل التالي 70% قالوا انها
ستكون حاسمه في تحديد الفائز بينما اعتبر
30% انها ستظهر حده الاستقطاب دون حسم
للفائز
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسحه رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات ويتجدد
يوميات تطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجد ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون ايضا في الحصاد هذا اليوم
في الولايات المتحده وزير الداخليه
الفرنسي جيرالدارمنا يحذر مما سماه ارهابا
اسلاميا سنيا ويعتبره ابرز تهديد لبلاده
واوروبا
[موسيقى]
البدايه اذا بتطورات الملف السوداني حيث
قالت مصادر في الخارجيه السعوديه للجزيره
ان الطرفيه النزاع وقع بالفعل على هدنه
الانسانيه لمده عشره ايام قابله للتمديد
وهي المرحله الثانيه من اعلان جده وكانت
القوات المسلحه السودانيه وقوات الدعم
السريع
بواسطه السعوديه بواسطه سعوديه والولايات
المتحده قد وقعت قبل نحو اسبوع اعلان جده
للالتزام بحمايه المدنيين في السودان وقد
اتفق الطرفان على الالتزام بسياده السودان
والحفاظ على وحدته كما اتفقا على ان مصالح
وسلامه الشعب السوداني هي اولويه رئيسيه
هذا وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الوزير انطوني بلينكر اتصل بقائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وناقش
المحادثات الجاريه في مدينه جده وافاد
البيان بيان الخارجيه الامريكيه بان
بلينكم جدد ادانته لاعمال العنف التي
ارتكبتها القوات المسلحه وقوه الدعم
السريع واضاف البيان ان بلينكن اكد
للبرهان ان التوصل لاتفاق في جده سيسمح
بتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه والخدمات
الاساسيه التي يحتاجها الشعب السوداني
بجده
هذا واقرب مفوض العون الانسانيه الاتحادي
في السودان نجم الدين عبد العزيز بصعوبه
الحديث في الوقت الراهن عن حلول خارج
اتفاق المبادئ الذي وقع في جده ووصف عبد
العزيز عقب لقائه في مدينه بورسودام
مندوبه منسق الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه وصف الوضع في الخرطوم بالمعقد
للغايه بسبب تحول العمليات العسكريه فيها
الى حرب عصابات وفق ما قال
طبعا الخرطوم وضعها وضعها معقد للغايه هي
منطقه عمل العسكريه او مستمره صحيح هناك
هدنه بموجب
اتفاق الجده ولكن طبيعه هذه الاشتباكات
وطبيعه هذه المعركه اصبحت اشبه بمعركه هي
حربي مدن وعصابات
على توقيع عن هذه الهدنه معنا من جده
مراسل الجزيره بدر اربعان بدر ماذا عن هذا
التوقيع هل من تفاصيل والاجواء وما تسرب
حتى الان عن هذا التوقيع
نعم عبد القادر نحن نتحدث عن الجوله
الثانيه من البحثات السودانيه بين طرفي
النزاع الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
والتي ما تزال مستمره هنا في جده برعايه
سعوديه امريكيه وبحضورهم بعوث الامم
الاضافه الى ممثل الرباعيه الدوليه وفقا
لمصادر دبلوماسيه في الخارجيه كانت قد
اكدت لنا ان الطرف هيا النزاع سيوقعان على
هدنه انسانيه مبدئيا لمده عشره ايام قابل
للتمديد وهي المرحله الثانيه من اعلان جده
والتي سيعقبها ايضا وفق ذات المصدر
وناقشات موسعه لوقف اطلاق نار دائم هذا
الحديث ياتي بعد القمه العربيه التي عقده
الام في جده والتي تحدث فيها ولي العهد
السعودي عن امله في ان تكون لغه الحوار هي
الاساس الحفاظ على وحده السودان وامن شعبه
ومقدراته ايضا رحب بتوقيع طرفي النزاع على
اعلان جده الالتزام بحمايه البدنيين
وتسهيل العمل الانساني كما ايضا عبر عن
امل يتم التركيز خلال المباحثات على وقف
فعال لاطلاق النار ايضا ومواصله المملكه
بالتعاون مع المجتمع الدولي بذل الجهود
الانسانيه وتف ما يتعلق بقنوات الاغاثه
للشعب السوداني نحن نتحدث عن مرحله
مباحثات الجاريه الاعلان المتوقع ان يتم
الاعلان عنه الليله تبحث في ترتيبات ايضا
تنفيذ اعلان جده على ارض الواقع بما فيها
مده التنفيذ فتح الممرات الانسانيه ايضا
تشكيل لجنه تثبت من تفيد الالتزامات اضافه
الى عدد من البنوته وقع عليها الطرفان في
الاعلان الاول ايضا هذه المباحثات تهدف
الى الى دراسه اليات ممكنه لانهاء النزاع
حقيقه لا يوجد سقف زمني محدد لهذه
المباحثات في جولتها الثانيه تجري بشكل
غير مباشر بين طرفي النزاع ينقل ما يقوله
طرفين نزاع عبر البسطاء الى القائمون على
هذا الملف الذين ايضا حثوا طرف
النزاع السوداني على استشعار المسؤوليه
وايضا انخراط بجديه في هذه المباحثات وخلق
ايجابي لها حقيقه اعلان جدا السابق كان قد
وضع خطوه ايجابيه باتجاه وضع ارضيه لنوع
التفاهمات بين الطرفين يلتزمون فيه
بالاعراف الدوليه والانتباه الى الم في
قائمه الاولويات قبل ان تكون مسؤوليه
المجتمع الدولي ايضا يؤطر
للعمل العسكري لاطراف النزاع على الارض
بعيدا عن النزاع الغير منضبط باطار انساني
اذا ما تحدثنا عن اصحاب المبادره
السعوديون والامريكيون هنا من واضح انهم
جادون في في رسم ملامح وخارطه الطريق
للخروج من هذه الازمه على الصعيد الانساني
والسياسي والعسكري وهذا ما يتضح
سيتضح من خلال اعلان البيان المتوقع ان
يصدر خلال ساعات بخصوص الهدنه التي توافق
عليها طرفي النزاع مساء امس كنا قد سالنا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان عن التطورات في هذا الملف تحديدا
ذكر بان يعني هناك تطورات ايجابيه ونوع من
الحديث الذي يعني يؤسس ربما لنوع من
الهدنه والتي ننتظر ان يتم الاعلان عنها
مساء هذا اليوم
رجاء ذكرنا بمده هذه الهدنه وعن هذه
المرحله الثانيه من اتفاق الجده
نعم عبد القادر الهدنه من المتوقع مبدئيا
ما طرح ما تم الاقتراح هو عشره ايام قابله
للتمديد وقابله ايضا
للنقص بحسب الاتفاق الذي سيتوافق عليها
الجيش السوداني وايضا قوات الدعم السريع
بالترتيب طبعا مع اصحاب المبادره
على هذا الملف منذ ايام والمباحثات جاريه
هنا في جده ما بعد اعلان جده بدات الجوله
الثانيه نحن في انتظار ما سيتم الاعلان
عنه يعني حقيقه لا يوجد سقف عالي جدا في
البيان المتوقع ان يصدر ربما هو فقط
الهدنه المتوقع ان يتم الاعلان عنها
الحديث حقيقه هو ترقيه هذه المباحثات
الجاريه هنا في جده بين اطراف النزاع الى
مفاوضات جاده لرسم ملامح وخارطه طريق يتم
البناء عليها في الوصول الى مخرج لهذه
الازمه او ايضا حتى رؤيه ملامح ليتوافق
عليها الطرفان ارضيه يتم
حولها
لايجاد نوع من الفتح
يعني ايجاد حل لهذا النزاع من فتح الممرات
الانسانيه الالتزام على الاقل بنود
الاعلان الاول لجده والذي تحدث عن عدد ما
يقرب من سبع بنود من الالتزامات المفترض
ان يلتزم بها الطرفين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش السوداني كان هناك تغيرات هيكليه
في القياده السودانيه وهذا تحديث جديد في
ايضا في على الواقع السوداني اذا ما
تحدثنا عن المبعوث السوداني الذي نعم شكرا
لك بدر الربيع معنا من جده في ظل هذا
التطور معنا الان من الخرطوم مراسله
الجزيره الطاهر المرضي ومعه
نرصد الاجواء وربما عن هذه الخطوه خاصه في
بعدها الانسان وهذا التركيز الدولي هذه
الوساطه الامريكيه التعليقات الامريكيه
الاخيره على مساله البعد الانساني في هذه
الازمه السود انيه الطاهر
نعم هذه الهدنه هي المرحله الثانيه التي
كانت تحدث عنها
وخاصه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه بانه هنالك او
هذا الامر في هذه الازمه الحليه يتم على
مراحل المرحله الاولى كان هو اعلان جده
الذي يتحدث عن فتح مسارات واشياء اخرى
تتعلق بالقانون الانساني ثم جاءت هذه هي
المرحله الثانيه المتعلقه بالهدنه هذه
الهدنه بحسب المعلومات التي وصلت الينا من
مصادر في المفاوضات ان هذه الهدنه ستستمر
لمده سبعه ايام
ستكون ستطبق عمليا بعد 48 ساعه من توقيع
على هذا الاتفاق هذه الهدنه لربما تكون
هنالك ايضا لجنه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار
خلال هذه الهدنه وتعتبر خطوه مهمه وبدايه
لحل حقيقي لانهاء هذه الازمه خاصه وان
اعلان جده لم يكن مت او لم يطبق حرفيا حتى
تستطيع الجهات التي تريد ان تنفذه من
الناحيه الانسانيه بفتح مسارات وازاله
المراكز والارتكازات في الشوارع العامه
ومنع التحرك المواطنين التي اعاده
المستشفيات الى الخدمه كل هذا لم يتم من
خلال اعلان جده ولكن يبدو ان هذه الخطوه
ستكون اكثر جديه وخاصه وان هنالك حرص كبير
من المجتمع الدولي وخاصه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمجتمع الاقليمي بان تكون هذه
الهدنه هدنه عمليه تجدد تلقائيا وتطور ثم
لاحقا تتطور الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
لان الاوضاع الانسانيه بدات الان في
التفاقم بعد دخول هذه الحرب
لشهر الثاني وبالتالي كان هنالك مناشده من
المجتمع السوداني من كل الفاعلين في
المجتمع السوداني والاقليمي والدولي بان
الاوضاع الانسانيه لا تحتمل خاصه ونلوم
المتحده تحدثت عن تقارير نزوح هو ولجوء
اكثر من مليون شخص جراء هذه الحرب والحرب
ما تزال مشتعله اليوم كان هنالك تصعيد
لهذه الحرب في دارفور خاصه في مدينه نيالا
ثم هنا في الخرطوم في درمان في بحري في
وسط الخرطوم اذا نتحدث عن حرب مستمره
وتداعيات انسانيه كبيره هذه الهدنه التي
وقعت اليوم ستكون لها اثر ايجابيه اذا ما
تم الالتزام بها من الطرفين وكانت هنالك
لجنه مراقبه حقيقيه لتنفيذ هذه الهدنه على
الارض ربما تفتح المسارات خاصه وان هنالك
تداعيات انسانيه كبيره وهنالك حوجه ماسه
لمساعدات سواء كانت هذه المساعدات طبيه او
كانت مساعدات غذائيه الامم المتحده تتحدث
عن ان الحاجه اكثر من اثنين مليون دولار
نصف سكان السودان الان في حاجه ماسه لهذه
المساعدات الانسانيه اذا ربما تكون هذه
الهدنه هي بدايه حقيقيه لعمليه وقف اطلاق
النار ووقف هذا التدهور الذي اصاب ايضا
الاوضاع الانسانيه في السودان الكل هنا
كان ينتظر هذا الامر وكان ينتظر توقيع هذه
الهدنه وهذا الاتفاق ويامل ان تكون هذه
بدايه حقيقيه لنهايه هذه الازمه شكرا لك
طهر المرضي ونبقى في الخرطوم هذه المره مع
ضيفنا عطاف مختار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
العطاف كيف وجدت هذا الاتفاق عن هذه الغده
او ما يصطلح في المرحله الثانيه من اتفاق
جده ماذا عن مؤشراتها
اهلا وسهلا
وفي المستشفيات
في مراكز الكهرباء وفي مراكز
محطات المياه الرئيسيه
وكذلك مطار مفهوم
شرق التي ستر عليها الدعم السريع التي
يتحدث عن اخلاء سريع جدا لهذه المراكز وكل
المناطق المسيطره عليها تعمل
السريع انا اعتقد هذه الفتنه
رهينه في الالتزام الطرفين لعدم
اطلاق النار وعدم اتفاقم الوضع لانه الوضع
الانساني على الارض محدثه الان وهنالك
المئات من المرضى الذين لقوا حذفكم ليس
بالرصاص وانما لانعدام
الانسانيه او نقص الدواء تتحدث مثلا عن
الامراض المزمنه
السرطانات
المرضى باعتقادك باعتقادك ما المؤشرات
التي على اساسها يمكن القول بان هناك
التزام او تطور في التعاطي مع الهدن
المتتاليه طبعا فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الالتزام ما المؤشرات التي على اساسها
نقيس مدى الالتزام بهذه الهدن
اولا الطرفين انه شعبه
باطينه وهولاء الذين من المفترض ان يكونوا
هم ح النظر
هذه الحرب يجب ان توقف هذه الحرب يجب ان
توقف هذا التمر سريع الذي
نفقه ويكان يكاد ان يقسمها الى دويلات
عديده ايضا الضغط الذي مورث على التطين من
قبل
السودان او من قبل الولايات المتحده او
كما شهدنا قبل قليل بعواجلكم عن التحدث
ايضا هنالك مراقبه ستتم لهذا الاتفاق
اعتقد في تم اتجاه المشتركه من الولايات
المتحده من السعوديه ايضا من الطرفين كذلك
سيتم استخدام فيها الاقمار الصناعيه او
المراقبه
الحراريه على على الارض من المهم جدا
الالتزام بهذا الامر ايضا تسميه مطارات
عديده ان اردت انها لك او مراكز عديده
ايضا لتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه وفي
الشرق او في وسط السودان او في ضرب
السودان او في السطوم او في ابيض
الرسمي ايضا
الطرق وايضا ميناء برسل الت
ذالك اما نازحين او لاجئين هذا العدد
سيتضاعف سنتحدث عن ثلاثه مليار دولار
هو مبلغ مبدئي يعني قالت الامم المتحده
يتم انزال المساعدات
الانسانيه نحن نناقشطه
الطرفان بضروره ضبط النفس في هذا الشعب
السوداني الذي اصبح الان مشردا الذي عاش
حياته كلها في عروبات اهليه لا نريد ان
تنزل
ق شكرا لك من الخرطوم مع عطاف المختار
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
بالامتار كانت القوه الروسيه وميليشيا
فاجنر تعلن تقدمها في بخموت بمعاكسه
استعصاء رغم سيطرتها شبه الكامله على
المدينه منذ اشهر عديده لكن اعلان
مالكي صفحتي باخموت وسيطره قواته بشكل
كامل عليها قبل بتصريحات اوكرانيه تقول
انها لم تسقط بعد لكنهم قد ينسحبون منها
بخموت ومدن اخرى تركت بصمتها في عمر حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا يتعرف على الاحداث في
التقرير التالي
المدينه الصغيره في منطقه دنيت الشرقيه
اوكرانيا حيزا كبيرا من يوميات حرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا وهي من اسخن جبهات القتال
منذ عده اشهر بين القوه الاوكرانيه والقوه
الروسيه ومعها ميليشي لضيق المسافات
وقربها في معارك السيطره يتحدث الكل
باللغه الامطار
اعلن السيطره قواته على كامل المدينه
بينما يسيطر الاوكرانيون مؤقتا على نحو
نصف كيلومتر مربع اما المتحدث باسم
القياده الشرقيه الاوكرانيه فقال ان قوتهم
تنفذ عمليه لتطويق وان العمليه الدفاعيه
اصبحت اشكاليه وان اجلا ام عاجلا ولاسباب
امنيه سيخرجون من بخموت وتشكل نتائج الوضع
على جبهه بخموت اهميه لكلا الطرفين فبسط
السيطره الروسيه عليها تهديد لمدن رئيسيه
اخرى مجاوره ابرزها سلوفيانسك
واكراماتورسك مركز العمليات الاوكرانيه
تعيد
بتطوراتها للاذهان جبهات اخرى ساخنه شكلت
محطات مفصليه في عمر الحرب وبينها حصار
ماريوبل وتحديدا حصار كتيبه ازوف لاسابع
في مصنع ازوف ستال للصلب اخر معاقل القوات
الاوكرانيه واوده المعركه والحصار وفقا
للمسؤولين الاوكرانيين بارواح ما يزيد عن
25 الف مدني خرسون ايضا هي مركز المحافظه
الوحيد الذي استطاعت القوه الروسيه
السيطره عليه خلال حربها على اوكرانيا مع
انطلاق الدبابات والمدرعات الروسيه من شبه
جزيره القرن في يوم الحرب الاول لكنه
هجوما اوكرانيا مضضا هي اغسطس من العام
الماضي فرضا انسحابا روسيا من المدينه في
نوفمبر وتم تفجير الجسور بين ضيفتي نهر
دنيبرو وخاركاب في شرق اوكرانيا على بعد
نحو 20 ميلا فقط جنوب الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وهي ثاني اكبر مدينه في
اوكرانيا وشكلت هدفا رئيسيه للجيش الروسي
منذ بدايه الحرب استعادها الاوكرانيون عبر
هجوم مضاد بدا في الخامس من شهر سبتمبر
الماضي وتبقى معركه كييف واحده من اهم
المعارك في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حينما
سعت القوات الروسيه للسيطره على
اجل تطويق ومحاصره العاصمه الاوكرانيه من
الغرب والتراث القوات الروسيه حينها مع
تقدم الجيش الاوكراني للانسحاب في الثاني
من ابريل من العام الماضي بينما كشف في
بوتشا عن اكثر من مقبره جماعيه ضمت نحو
458 جثه
عن هذا الملف معنا من الدكتوره اللادا
روزيلزكي مؤسسه ومديره مجموعه بلاك
للاستثمارات الامنيه والدفاعيه ومعي من
موسكو الكسندر
منائب مدير معهد الاستشراف والتسويه
السياسيه لحالات النزاع اهلا بكم وابدا
بضيف من موسكو السيده الكسندر كوزينتسوف
عن هذا التاكيد من الجانب الروسي بانه بات
يسيطر بشكل كامل على بدي مدينه
كيف تجد هذه السيطره اخيره بعد كل هذه
الشهور والصعوبات التي واجهتها الروسيه
وعلى راسها قوه فاقنر
المعلومات حول السيطره على باخموت
لما اسمع بها من المصادر الروسيه لكن قبل
عشر دقائق فقط قرات مقالا في
صحيفه بريطانيه لا تتعاطف مع روسيا وذكر
في المقال ان
كانت قد سقطت بالكامل
وان مستر
ورئيس شركه فاجنر الخاصه
الذكر ان باخموت الان تقع تحت سيطره هذه
المجموعه العسكريه وان هذه اجل الشركه هذه
المجموعه ستقوم بتسليم المدينه في اقرب
وقت ممكن الى الجيش الروسي
بالتالي فان اخر الجنود الاوكرانيين
سينسحبون من باخموت
قبل يومين او ثلاثه كان هنالك السيطره على
منطقه تسمى ديل حيث ان القوات الاوكرانيه
تبقى ما تبقى من تلك القوات كانت موجوده
هناك لكنها انسحبت بسبب القصف الروسي
والقذف المدفعي والخسائر الكبيره التي
تكبدوها
اذا ما اعتمدنا على روايه السيد بريجوشن
بانه تمت السيطره على
كيف تجد هذا التقدم هذا النصر هل هو نصر
استراتيجي برايك بالنسبه للجانب الروسي
اعتقد بالتاكيد هو نصر لان باخ موت
تقع
في منطقه بموقع استراتيجي مهم لكنه ليس
نصر كامل
هذا نصر اولي
بالتالي فان القوات الاوكرانيه في ذلك في
هذه الجبهه قد انهزمت بالكامل ولا يمكنها
ان تقام بعد الان لكن الوضع سيعتمد على
التطورات الاضافيه المستقبليه للاحداث في
ارض المعركه هنالك بعض الخيارات للقوات
الروسيه واعتقد ان الخطوه التاليه ستكون
هجمه
وهي مدينه صغيره لكنها مهمه لان من تلك
المدينه بامكان القوات الروسيه ان تقشدنا
قصفا لمناطق دومباز بالتالي من المهم جدا
ان تسيطر على تلك المنطقه وهناك خيارات
اخرى او لم تتعرض القوات الروسيه وعلى
راسها قوات فيرنا الى عمليه استنزاف كل
هذه الشهور للسيطره على هذه المدينه بمعنى
الاخر هل حجم الخسائر حتى الان
يكافئ
تحقيق هذا التقدم
يه نعم نعم
اعتقد ان قوه
ستنسحب من مواقعها لان هذه هؤلاء
هؤلاء
المقاتلين قالوا انهم سيقاتلون لمده اربع
مئه يوم بدون اي اجازه او استراحه هم
كمجموعه يحتاجون الى هذه الراحه وهنالك
قوات روسيه جديده سيتم نشرها في تلك
المنطقه
اعتقد انهم سيقومون
هجمه تجاه دافيه ايضا هنالك خيارات اخرى
بشن هجوم جوي الامر سيعتمد كما قلت على
الوضع على في الارض
النائب مدير معهد الاستشراف والتسويه
السياسيه لحالتي النزاع شكرا جزيلا لك
لاعود لظيفته الى كيف الدكتوره
ومديره مجموعه بلاك رايت للاستثمارات
للاستشارات الامنيه
والدفاعيه الدكتوره اللادا
ضخمه الان على الاقل حسب التاكيد الجانب
القائد مجموعه فاجنر بانها اصبحت تحت
سيطره قواته او لو لم يكن من الاجدر
بالنسبه للجانب الاوكراني باعتبار ان منذ
شهور اعتبرت بخموت ساقطه عسكريا في يد
الجانب الروسي اولا يكن من الاجدى توفير
كل هذا الجهد وهذه الارواح
حتى الوصول الى هذه النتيجه
اعتقد ان من الافضل للناس ان يفهموا ان
هذه اراضي اوكرانيه مجموعه فاجنور هي قوه
عسكريه خاصه مجموعه عسكريه خاصه تابعه
لروسيا والاخبار التي
اتت من طباخي بوتين هي خاطئه فان مدينه
باقمت باكملها لم يتم السيطره عليها ومن
المهم جدا لمن يشاهدنا الان ان يفهم ان
هنالك فيما يتعلق بخطط روسيا لاوكرانيا
وايضا الدول الاخرى في العالم هو ان يكون
هنالك ارتكاب
لاباده جماعيه هنالك سياسه الارض المحروقه
التي تتبعها روسيا ويجب ان وما الذي متوقع
من اوكرانيا ان تتراجع عن هذه المدينه ان
مساله كونها مدينه او
مدينه واحده
هذا اعتداء ارتكبه الروس للقانون الدولي
قاموا بشن حرب
بربريه وغير قانونيه مرفوضه من القانون
الدولي وهو وضع صعب للغايه اذا من الناحيه
الاستراتيجيه فان يكون هنالك
هنالك سعي منذ الانتهاء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه ان يكون هنالك لكن بدون الحقيقه
لن يكون هنالك امكانيه بان هذا التراجع
طبعا في انتظار التاكيد الرسمي بان باخمه
ما زالت محل نزاع وانه تم السيطره عليها
من قبل الجانب الروسي الن تؤثر هذه
النتيجه على معنويات القوات الاوكراني وهي
تستعد لما يصطلح عليه بالهجوم المضاد
المنتظر
مضاده الجميع
ينتظرها لكن الروح المعنويه للجيش
الاوكراني لا يمكن ان تتاثر لان هذه حرب
وجوديه يخوضها الجيش الروس قرروا ان يقضوا
على الامه الاوكرانيه باكملها بالتالي اي
خساره قد تكون صغيره لكنها تقوم بتعزيز
الروح المعنويه للجيش الاوكراني لاننا اذا
لم نقاتل سنموت السؤال هو ما هو الدعم
الاخلاقي
والمادي الذي
تستلمه اوكرانيا من اجل ان تنجو الامر مهم
جدا ان ندرك ان اوكرانيا هي اكثر البلدان
ثراء في
القاره الاوروبيه لدينا الغاز الليثيوم
الذهب وايضا ثروات طبيعيه اخرى ان القضاء
على الشعب الاوكراني هو
هو امر تهدف اليه روسيا وما تقوم به
مجموعه
ان اقول لك واكذلك لك ليس هنالك
ليس هنالك اكادير من وجود الكثير من
الضحايا علينا ان نتحدث ان القانون الدولي
قد خرق وانا متاكد انه لا احد يريد ان
اعتذر منك ادركنا الوقت
مديره ومؤسسه مجموعه بلاكه للاستثمارات
الاستشارات الامنيه والدفاعيه كنت معنا من
كيف
للمراه الحاديه عشره على التوالي خلال شهر
مايو الجاي تتعرض لهجوم مكثف تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه انه نفذ بثماني عشره مسيره
انتحاريه واسفر عن اضرار في احياء مختلفه
من المدينه وسط تحذيرات الاداره العسكريه
للعاصمه من استنزاف الدفاعات الجويه مراسل
الجزيره حسان مسعود رصد وصول احدى
المسيرات الى وسط كياب واثار الهجمات على
سكان المدينه
عزيز رعب يحوم في الاجواء مجددا
مسيره انتحاريه عبرت فوق ميدان الاستقلال
وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه بالتزامن مع
انفجارات لم تهدا
قضت مضاجع السكان فهرعوا الى الملاجئ قبل
ان تعترضها الدفاعات الجويه في محيط القصر
الرئاسي
لكن مسيره اخرى كان قصفها اكثر قوه
صور التقطها احد سكان احياء كييف اظهرت
اثار الهجوم الجديد بثماني عشره مسيره كما
قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه هجوم احدث اثرا
بالغا في ممتلكات كما في نفوس الاوكرانيين
هذا هو الاستهداف الحادي عشر منذ بدايه
شهر مايو ما يعني انهم يهاجموننا كل ليله
تقريبا هذه لم تعد حربا هذا اصبح عملا
ارهابيا بحقنا
اضرار ماديه لحقت باحياء مختلفه في
العاصمه نجمت ايضا عن حطام المسيرات التي
تقول السلطات انها اسقطتها جميعا لكنه
وصولها الى مناطق سكنيه وتجاريه قد يعني
اختراقها للدفاعات المحيطه بالمدينه ما
يزيد من الضغط على السكان
ما يجري مؤلم للغايه هذا مصدر رزق الوحيد
وقد تعرض لاضرار لا يمكن اصلاحها لكن
للروس راي اخر لا اعلم ما علينا فعله الان
هي معركه مفتوحه مع الدفاعات الجويه براي
المسؤولين العسكريين الذين ينتظرون تعزيز
قدراتها بالطائرات الحربيه
يريدون ان يهاجموا مراكز صنع القرار في
بلدنا ومنظومات دفاعاتنا الجويه
واستنزافها عبر هذه الهجمات الموسعه لكننا
نتصدى لهم ونعلم ان شركائنا سيزودوننا
بالمزيد منها وربما كذلك بالطائرات
الحربيه التي ستساعد دفاعاتنا الجويه
ظلنا سكان العاصمه هذه المشاهد باتت من
الماضي لكن الهجمات المكثفه اعادتها الى
الاذهان رغم مرور اكثر من عام على الحرب
وسط تحضيرات من استنزاف الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ما قد يجعل الخطر على العاصمه
اكبر واقرب حسن مسعود الجزيره كييف
[موسيقى]
اكد رؤساء الدول الاعضاء في مجموعه السبع
في ختام قمتهم بمدينه هيروشيما الاستمرار
في محاسبه روسيا ومن يدعمها بسبب حربها
على اوكرانيا واكد قاده الدول السبع في
بيان التزامهم بدعم اوكرانيا مهما تطلب
احلال السلام الشامل من وقت ودعوا الصين
الى الضغط على روسيا بشان الحرب في
اوكرانيا كما رفضوا عسكره الصين منطقه
اسيا والمحيط الهادئ حسب ما جاء في البيان
وتعهدوا بالالتزام بتحقيق عالم خالي من
الاسلحه النوويه
منذ خمسين عاما يجتمعوا قاده اكبر سبعه
اقتصادات في العالم سنويا قد يصعب تذكر
اسماء بعض تلك القمم اما قمه هيروشيما هذه
فستبقى محفوره في الذاكره لوقت طويل
لرمزيه المكان ولانها شكلت حدثا تاريخيا
كما وصفها رئيس الوزراء الياباني
لكن الرساله التي يواجهها من مدينه تعرضت
للقصف الذري ويسميها اليابانيون مدينه
السلام لا تبدو ناصعه البياض
فالصفحات الاربعون للبيان الختامي للقمه
فيها وعيد وتحذيرات غير مسبوقه تضع مجموعه
السبع على مسار تصادمي مع اثنتين من اكبر
القوى العسكريه في العالم بل والنوويه
روسيا والصين
يقول البيان ان دول السبع ملتزمه بتعزيز
دعمها الدبلوماسي والاقتصاديه والعسكري
لاوكرانيا مهما طال الزمن لزياده تكلفه
الحرب على روسيا وعلى الدول التي تقف الى
جانبها
ويبدو ان حضور الرئيس الاوكراني
اجتماعات القمه سيترجم تلك التعهدات عمليا
فللمره الاولى ستكون هناك اليه لمراقبه
وتحضير الدول التي تساعد موسكو على
الالتفاف على العقوبات الدوليه بتسويق
الثروات الروسيه من ذهب والماس ومعادن
ثمينه كما اتفق الدول السبع على دعم تسليم
اوكرانيا طائرات اف 16
وتتولى الولايات المتحده تدريب طيارها
في مارس الماضي في مدينه ساندييغو وقفنا
معا وكان معنا حينها رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك للنعل عن الالتزام
بالامن المشترك من خلال شراكتنا الثلاثيه
اوكوس لقد وقفت استراليا والولايات
المتحده معا للدفاع عن القيم المشتركه بما
في ذلك دعم الشعب الاوكراني في الدفاع عن
نفسه ضد العدوان الروسي الوحشي
حرصت اليمن وعلى ان تكون للصين حصه جيده
من البيان الختامي ايضا فطوكيو تضيق ذرعا
بازدياد النفوذ العسكري والاقتصادي
لجارتها وفي عشره بنود حذرت فيها مجموعه
السبع الصين من استخدام قوتها الاقتصاديه
سلاحا لفرض هيمنتها
وتعهدت باطلاق مبادره لمراقبه الاكراه
الاقتصادي ومساعده الدول والكيانات على
محاربته اما تايوان فيجب الا تحاول بيجين
تغيير الوضع القائم فيها بالقوه وعليها ان
لا تقوض الامن والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
موقف ودعوات يؤيدها زعماء ثمان دول دعيت
لحضور قمه السبع اهمها الهند واستراليا
اللتان تشكلان مع اليابان والولايات
المتحده مجموعه الحوار الامني الرباعي
انعقاد قمه السبع في هيروشيما يحمل رمزيه
كبيره فهي مدينه سلام تدعو لعالم خال من
الاسلحه النوويه لكن التحذيرات الشديده
اللهجه في بيان القمه ضد روسيا لحربها في
اوكرانيا والصين لضغوطها الاقتصاديه
والعسكريه اوجدت مخاوف من تحول القمه الى
نقطه انطلاق لمواجهه بين هذه القوى
العالميه
تحديدا الاتفاق وقع في جده بين الطرفي
النزاع وما يرجع حتى الان من معلومات عن
الطريق مصادر الجزيره عن مضمون هذا
الاتفاق الذي ينص على وقف اطلاق النار بين
طرفي النزاع في السودان اكد على احتفاظ
الجانبين بمواقع بمواقع سيطرتهما كذلك
الالتزام بفتح ممرات انسانيه لتسهيل وصول
المساعدات
للمدنيين وكذلك الاتفاق ينص على وقف القصف
بالطائرات والمدافع الثقيله وكذلك
المسيرات وهذا الاتفاق
لطرفي النزاع في السودان اكد على دوره
التزام بالابتعاد قدر الامكان عن
المستشفيات وعن استعمال كما ذكرنا
الطائرات والمدافع الثقيله والمسيره
نعود لملف
اتفاق او اجتماع مجموعه
السبع حيث نقلت رويترز عن مسؤول امريكي ان
رئيس جو بايدن سيرين حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه
375 مليون دولار اثناء وجوده في هيروشيما
في قمه قاده مجموعه دول السبع وذكر
المسؤول ان حزمه المساعدات الجديده ستشمل
المدفعيه والذخيره وصواريخ هاي مارس
من جهته اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسي
سيرجينا الدول الغربيه بمحاوله هزيمه
بلاده والقضاء عليها كمنافس جيوسي حسب
تعبيره واضاف الافروف ان الغرب حدد مهمته
بالقضاء على روسيا كمنافس جيوسي وهو ما
تمثل في القرارات التي اتخذت في قمه
هيروشيما التي تهدف الى الرضع المزدوج
لروسيا والصين بحسب تعبيره
لقد حددوا المهمه بصوت عال وبشكل علني
هزيمه روسيا في ساحه المعركه ولا يتم
التوقف عند هذا الحد بل القضاء عليها
كمنافس جيوسياسي وبطبيعه الحال سيتم ردع
اي بلد اخر يدعي نوعا من الاستقلاليه في
النظام العالمي انظروا الى القرارات التي
يجري اتخاذها في قمه مجموعه السبع الكبار
في هيروشيما والتي تهدف الى الرضع المزدوج
لروسيا والصين لروسيا العديد من الحلفاء
نحن لا نشجع العداء تجاه اي كان لكننا
مضطرون لل بحزم على الحرب المعلنه ضدنا
هذا وانتقدت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه من
جانبها عدم تطرق مجموعه السبع لمعارضه
استقلال تايوان وقالت في بيان التواطؤ مع
القوه المؤيده لاستقلال يؤثر على استقرار
مضيق تايوان واضاف البيان ان مجموعه السبع
استخدمت القضايا المتعلقه بالصين لتشويه
سمعتها وتدخل في شؤونها ووصف ذلك بانه
عرقله للسلام وتقويض للاستقرار الاقليمي
بحسب البيان
معنى من لندن الدكتور زينو ليوني الاستاذ
بجامعه
والمحاضر في تحديث او تحديات النظام
العالمي اهلا بك دكتور زينو وانقل لك رد
الفعل وزير الخارجيه الروسي الذي وصف ما
جرى في قمه هيروشيما بانه محاوله للقضاء
جيوسياسيا على دوله اسمها روسيا وانه كان
عباره عن عمليه رضع لدولتين هما روسيا
والصين هل وجدته كذلك
ان رد فعل في بالنسبه الى قمه مجموعه دول
السبع ليست مفاجئا بل هو متوقع وقد اثار
قضايا كثيره بدات مع الحرب على اوكرانيا
حيث كان هناك عوده الى سياسه القطبين
وقمه دول مجموعه السبعه كما نرى روسيا
والصين تتحولان الى كتله مع انهما لم يصل
الى هذا المرحله بعد ولكن
الدول مجموعه سبع ايضا تريد ان تقدم كتله
موحده من جهه اخرى من الموطمئن
ان هذه الدول لا تريد فك الارتباط بل تريد
الحد من المخاطر وهذا مختلف هذا يظهر
لماذا هذه العلاقه بين الغرب وروسيا
متدهوره مع انه لا يزال هناك امل بالنسبه
الى علاقه الدول الغرب مع الصين باشارتك
لموضوع الصين كانت هناك تصريحات سابقه
لوزير او للرئيس الفرنسي دعى فيها
الاوروبيين الى اخذ مسافه وعدم الانقياد
خلف الرؤيه والمقاربه الامريكيه حيال
الصين في النهايه هل انتصرت المقاربه
الامريكيه في قمه هيروشيما فيما يتعلق
بالصين
اعتقد ان هذا من شانه ان يتبلور اكثر على
المدى الطويل اعتقد انه لا شك فعلا الحرب
على اوكرانيا ساعدت الولايات المتحده على
تعزيز هذه الحجه
وعلى اقناع الكثير من الدول الاعضاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بان الصين بحاجه لمن
يواجهها لو كان ذلك سوف يشمل صداما
بالنسبه الى
مخرجات قمه دول السبع فهي تنظر لماذا او
ان هو صحيح ان الدول الاوروبيه تعتمد نفس
المواقف كلويات المتحده ولكنها لا تتبعه
بطريقه عمياء وهذا خبر
جيد للجميع يمكن الدول الاوروبيه ان تنتقد
الصين وان تحافظ على نوع من الاستقلاليه
وعلى الولايات المتحده ان تتقبل ذلك وهنا
هنا برز الحديث في تصريح القمه عن الحد من
المخاطر
بجامعه والمحاضر في تحديات النظام العالمي
شكرا جزيلا لك
اعتبر وزير الداخليه الفرنسي جيرالدرمانا
ان ما وصفه بالارهاب الاسلاموي السني هو
ابرز تهديد لبلاده ولاوروبا داعيا خلال
زياره الى الولايات المتحده لتعزيز
التعاون الامني مع واشنطن خصوصا قبل
استضافه باريس اولمبياد 2024 الصيفي وقال
دارمانا في تصريح لوكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
انه فيما يشكل التهديد الامني الاكبر في
الولايات المتحده عمليات اطلاق النار
الجماعي او الجماعات العنصريه فان اوروبا
تواجه الارهاب الاسلاموي السني كمصدر
تهديد من اشخاص وتنظيمات قد تكون من داخل
فرنسا او خارجها
معنى من باريس فرنسوا دوروش رئيس جمعيه
عداله وحقوق بلا حدود سيد فرنسا واين يمكن
وضع تصريحات وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه هل
باعتقادك هناك معلومات لدى الجانب الفرنسي
بنى على اساسها الوزير الفرنسي هذه
التصريحات ام هي مساله تقديريه
مساء الخير لكم وللمشاهدين
نحن ناسف لسماع هذه
التصريحات التي صدرت طريق عشوائيه من قبل
وزير الداخليه
يمكن ان نتحدث في فرنسا في الداخل الفرنسي
عن تنافسا بين اليمين المتطرف في الحكومه
واليسار المتطرف في المعارضه هناك تنافس
فعلا
من قبل اليمين المتطرف وانا
اوافق هذه المقوله اليوم للاسف هذا ما
يحصل في فرنسا بعد سنتين من القانون ضد
الانفصاليه اليوم حين يريد اي سياسي ان
يخلق هبه معينه او ان يكسب اصواتا ليس
هناك سوى سبيل واحد هو ينتقد الاسلام
يتحدث عن الاسلام السني او المعتدل او
الخفيف لايت
ويتحدث عن ذلك في محاوله من اجل ذر الرماد
في العيون للاسف هذا ما يحصل بعد القانون
الذي صدر منذ سنتين والذي فعلا اثر على
المواطنين
المسلمين اليوم يتم
التعرض لاحدى المدارس الفرنسيه
المسلمه وهي من الافضل في فرنسا في ليل
هناك مقوله تقول انه اذا اردت ان تقتل
شخصا ما فانت يمكنك ان تتهمه
بمرض معين نحن نتحدث هنا عن الكثيرين في
فرنسا الذين يحاولون ان يدعموا ماليا
اذا الذين يحاولون دعم الجمعيات الاسلاميه
والكثير منهم احيلوا امام القاده
لا يمكن للجمعيات الاسلاميه ان تعمل بدون
موارد
يبدو ان فرنسا تسير خاطئ باعتقادك
باعتقادك
منعكاسات تصريحات وزير الداخليه هذه اولا
على الداخل الفرنسي وخاصه المسلمين في
فرنسا
لم اسمع السؤال سالتك عن تاثير تصريحات
وزير الداخليه هذه على الداخل الفرنسي
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالمسلمين في فرنسا
في الحقيقه ان هذه هي التصريحات يا موجهه
الى المسلمين في الداخل الفرنسي لانه على
المستوى الوطني او على المستوى الوطني
ولكن حين نتحدث عن المستوى الخارجي لتوقيع
العقود ليس هناك اهتمام بما اذا كانوا سنه
او شيعه انظروا الى ما يحصل مع محمد بن
سلمان وما حصل اليوم مع جزار دمشق الذي
يعاد تاهيله وتقديمه بصوره ملمعه في القمه
العربيه اليوم هناك تركيز
على جلادين في هذا العالم من المسلمين
اتحدث هنا عن بعض القاده العرب يتم
توجيه اصبع اللوم الى عدد من الجمعيات
التي تقوم بعمل يمكن وصفه
بانه عمل منظم لانه اليوم حين يكون لدينا
صندوق التبرعات هناك دائما مسؤول من
الحكومه يشرف على اداره هذا النوع من
الصناديق وهذه الجمعيات لا يجب ان ننسى
اليوم ان
في فرنسا هناك تيارات
مختلفه هناك
ايضا على حقوق الانسان هناك حريه المعتقد
المعتقد الدينيه ولكن للاسف مع هذا
القانون الجديد هناك محاوله لخنق المسلمين
او تضيق الخناق عليهم وهذا ليس جيدا لا
للحريه المدنيه ولا لاطفالنا شكرا شكرا لك
ادركنا الوقت من باريس رئيس جمعيه عداله
وحقوق بلا حدود وانت معنا من باريس
بالعوده الى التطورات في السودان وبتزامن
مع تزايد حده الاشتباكات في الخرطوم ومثلث
مدنها تستعر حرب اخرى في الغرب السوداني
بالتحديد في اقليم دارفور بالتزامن مع
قرار البرهان اقاله حميتي من منصب نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده وتعيين مالك عقار رئيس
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان في مكانه
حيث تدور معارك للسيطره على مراكز مدن
ولايات دارفور تتضارب الروايات بشان
مجرياته
[تصفيق]
غير بعيد عن نيال شهدت مدينه زالينجي
عاصمه ولايه وسط دارفور اشتباكات ضاريه
بين الطرفين وشمالا الى الفاشر عاصمه
ولايه شمال دارفور لم تسلم هي الاخرى من
الاشتباكات وتتحدث المصادر من داخلها عن
سقوط قتلى والجرحى واعمال حرق وتوقف
للخدمات الصحيه لكن توافقا مؤقتا بين
سكانها وحركات مسلحه الناشطه في المدينه
يبدو انه ادى الى توافق لوقف القتال وان
كان هشا ولا يعرف حتى الان مدى قدرته على
الصمود اما في مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه
غرب دارفور فوصف حاكم الولايه الوضع فيها
بالكارثي حيث ادت الاشتباكات الى تشريد
الالاف الى تشاد ومع اتساع رقعه القتال في
الغرب ومناطق دارفور تحديدا المعروفه
بانها خزان الدعم السريع ومعقل قوه حميتي
فان الحرب في السودان تاخذ منحا مختلفا
ينذر بنبش تاريخ من الصراعات في الاقليم
المنكوب
اذا في تفاصيل ما تشهده الجبهات في غرب
السودان تجددت في مدينه النيال عاصمه
ولايه جنوب دارفور شباك تزامنا مع موجات
فرار في المناطق القريبه من قياده الجيش
سوداني خاصه في حي من حي الوادي قوات
الدعم السريه تتمركز في الناحيه الشرقيه
لمدينه نيالا بينما يوجد الجيش داخل وحول
مقر قيادته في الناحيه الغربيه في مدينه
زالنجي عاصمه ولايه وسط دارفور واحدى
معاقل قبيله الفور تدور اشتباكات وتتحدث
قوات الدعم السريعا تصديها لهجوم من قوات
الجيش السوداني وقعت خلال الايام الماضيه
ايضا معارك طالت مدينه الجنينه عاصمه
ولايه غرب دارفور هذه المره وادت الى مقتل
واصابه العشرات ولجوء الالاف لدوله تشاد
المجاوره وتاثر بالمعارك المطار الوحيد
الموجود على مستوى الولايه
ومنذ اليوم الاول لاندلاع المعارك شهدت
مدينه الفاشر عاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور وهي
مدينه متنوعه الاثنيات شهدت اشتباكات وسقط
بسببها قتلى وجرحى ورغم توصل لمكونات
سياسيه واهليه ومسلحه الى اتفاق لوقف
القتال في شمال دارفور فانه ظل هشا هذا
الاتفاق هذا وتستدعي جبهات المواجهه
المشتعله في غرب دارفور في غرب السودان
عفوا القاء نظره على ابرز القوه
والتشكيلات العسكريه الفاعله هناك بدايه
الحركه العدل والمساوات يقودها وزير
الماليه حاليا جبريل ابراهيم ثم حركه جيش
تحرير السودان يقودها حاكم اقليم دار فور
حاليا من ناوي ثم حركه تجمع تحرير السودان
يقودها عضو المجلس السيادي حاليا الطاهر
حجر وكذلك حركه تحرير السودان المجلس
يقودها عضو مجلس السياده بالسودان الهادي
ادريس في الاستوديو معنا عادل الباز
الكاتب والمحلل والصحفي ورئيس تحرير صحيفه
الاحداث السودانيه اهلا بك سيد عادل تعيين
مالك عقار في هذا التوقيت بعد كل هذه
الفتره من الاقتتال يدفعنا لمحاوله فهم
الاسباب التي تقف خلف هذا التعيين اعتقد
عقاره من اوائل الشخصيات القياديه في
حركات التحرير الاستجابه لنداء السلام
وذهب الى جوبا وتفاوض مع الحكومه من ضمن
الجبهه الثوريه ووقع اتفاق وهو رجل معروف
يعني بخبرته الطويله وكان كان متمرزا
سابقا وكان
حاكمني الى الازرق
وشخصيه معروفه
وتتميز بالكاريزما يعني ورجل له تاريخ
طويل في العمل السياسي والعمل العسكري
يعني ولذلك اعتقد ان
اختيار مالك في هذا الظرف خلف اختيار موفق
انه مقبول من كل الاطراف السودانيه مقبول
من السياسيين كلهم سواء كانت في المعارضه
او الناس الحكومه وهو له درايه بديوان
الدوله لانه ظل موجود في في
مجلس السياده
الجغرافي علاقه بهذا التعيين
من الكلام حول الاقاليم المهمشه في
السودان انها لا تلقى حظها من الثروه او
السلطه ولذلك وجود شخص كمالك عقار يطمن
هذه الاقاليم بان حقوقها محفوظه وهي تمثل
في اعلى
يعني المناصب في الدوله واعتقد ان دلاله
جيده ان يكون مالك عقار
لمرح كما ذكرت يعني وقف على مسافه واحده
من الطرفين فهذا مؤشر لشيء قادم باعتقادك
هذا مؤشر لدور اكبر يلعب مالك عقار في
تكسير العلاقه بين الفرقاء المتغافلين
وبين الجيش والحركه المدنيه لانه مالك
عمله مع الحركه المدنيه وما هذه الاحزاب
فتره طويله جدا
حينما كان يعني في الجبهه السوريه ونداء
السودان ولذلك له علاقات واسعه فتجسير هذا
اللقاء مالك واصلح زول الان يمكن ان يلعب
هذا الدور هل في ثلاثين في عشر ثواني هل
المنصب نائب مجلس السياده يمكنه من ذلك
اعتقد نعم اذا قبلت اذا كل الاطراف لن
تقبل بمالك انا لم اسمع النقد يعني
الحكومه وافقت عليه الاطراف الحركه
المسلحه
وافقت عليه اطراف السياسيه لم يستنكر احد
الى الان او يرفض تعيين مالك نائب للبرهان
شكرا لك عادل الباز الكاتب الصحفي ورئيس
تحري صحيفه الاحداث السداريه شكرا جزيلا
لك
وبالملف السوداني نختم ملفات حصاد هذه
الليله الى جوله منتصف الليل مع فدا وحسن
اليكم في دواء حسن